good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson Tech we do not want to deliver
another depressing show and we won't but
if you're looking at the country and
thinking how do we measure the health of
the United States they're pretty obvious
ways to do it the average life
expectancy is one the marriage rate the
effectiveness of the US military housing
costs the value of the US dollar the
health of the financial markets the
safety of our streets Etc by every
single one of those very basic measures
the bite Administration has failed and
done so dramatically Biden isn't simply
incompetent though obviously he is Biden
is the single most destructive force in
the history of the United States
in just a year and a half Biden and Ron
Clane his strange shadowy Chief of Staff
have done more damage to this country
than anybody could possibly have
imagined we read the numbers every night
but they don't capture it you know what
captures it this story this story comes
from the reliably liberal financial news
outlets CNBC here's the second sentence
of the piece quote a rising number of
former Californians are migrating out of
the country altogether and are instead
heading South of the Border many are
seeking a more relaxed and affordable
lifestyle in Mexico
yes in Mexico not Switzerland Mexico
so things are so bad in Joe Biden's
America that thousands of Americans are
voluntarily moving to a third world
country in the middle of a brutal drug
war
yes there are human heads littering the
side of the road in Acapulco but at
least it's not Los Angeles
Daryl Graham Works in real estate in
Mexico he says of the people he sells to
quote at least half are coming down from
California something the cost of taxes
the crime rates the politics all the
things that people are unhappy with in
California make them want to come down
to Mexico
another annual analyst who studies the
trend at the migration policy Institute
says so many Americans are relocating to
Mexico right now that locals are being
priced out of their own neighborhoods
so it's Mass migration in reverse
it's pretty amazing
no matter how bad you thought this
Administration was going to be you
probably could not have imagined ever
Caravans of Biden refugees fleeing our
country across the southern border
looking for a better life in Mexico at
this rate the next stop will be
Port-au-Prince see what you all about
Haiti it's better than Baltimore
now one upside of moving to Latin
America is like-minded Neighbors
Hispanics despise Joe Biden too Biden's
approval rating among Hispanic voters in
this country has fallen to 24 that's his
lowest among any demographic group
meanwhile as of tonight guess who's
their preferred candidate for 2024 among
self-described Latinos that's right the
taco bowl guy Donald J Trump let that
sink in for a second Donald Trump
supposedly the most anti-hispanic racist
this country has ever produced that man
is far more popular among actual
Hispanics than a cringing white liberal
like Joe Biden so the guy who tried to
build a border wall is loved the guy who
uses the words latinx non-ironically is
hated
remarkable
it's also and this is not an
overstatement politically a disaster of
generational magnitude for the
Democratic Party
Latinos dislike Joe Biden intensely and
they dislike him for the same reason
that everybody else does Biden has made
things worse a lot worse
the median income in this country is
forty four thousand dollars a year a
year
imagine trying to live on that right now
do the math you couldn't do it not in
any recognizably American Way inflation
is too high
it's making you poorer well today in
Philadelphia Joe Biden unveiled his plan
to fix inflation now watch this taping
keep in mind as you do that it is real
we've not edited it in any way here it
is
we can do all this
I'm asking
all I'm asking is for the largest
corporations are the wealthiest
Americans
to begin to pay their fair share in
taxes
I'm deadly earnest
anybody out there think
the tax system is fair raise your hand
this guy the AFL-CIO how many private
sector labor union members support Joe
Biden 12 15 it's not 50 and yet they
host the guy they're so corrupt but
listen to the message higher taxes will
make the things that you buy cheaper
that's what Biden just said inflation is
up because taxes aren't High Enough
now it's hardly a defense of corporate
America which we would never defend to
point out that that as an economic
analysis is completely insane it's not
true we've lost control of inflation
because people like Joe Biden pushed a
species of lunacy called modern monetary
Theory they printed an endless torrent
of fake money to enrich and Empower
themselves and by doing that they
crashed the US dollar and made you much
poorer that's what happened
there's not much debate about that now
they're not going to acknowledge it of
course they can't even be bothered to
pretend to care about baby formula
shortages
here's Joe Biden's publicist just
yesterday
so I have two questions on baby formula
so first um what is the White House what
is the latest update the White House has
received on the current info formula
situation across the country yeah let me
see if I have anything new for you on
that
um
I think it's been a couple of days since
we have asked me to ask that question
okay
I don't have anything new I know we made
some announcements last week I don't I
just don't have them in front of me
oh mothers can't feed their babies let
me see what I have here
somehow the White House communications
team forgot to load the baby formula
talking points into the binder leaving
our historic lgbtq plus immigrant class
ceiling shattering press secretary
speechless I just don't have them in
front of me
in other words what does that question
have to with trans rights nothing okay
next
the one thing Karine Jean-Pierre can't
say with dead certainties that Joe Biden
is great Joe Biden is energetic he's
fully in charge of his faculties in fact
he's planning on running again in 2024
by which time all of suburban Chicago
will have moved to Haiti in search of a
higher standard of living
she actually said that quote to be clear
as the president himself has said
repeatedly he plans to run in 2024. and
we can just guess how you feel about
that but how do leaders of the
democratic party feel about that he's
their guy and yet they're horrified by
it even Sandy Cortez who can defend
anything if she has to up tune including
other pointless neocon war in Ukraine
even she can't get behind another Joe
Biden run watch
we'll cross that bridge when we get to
it but
um but I think if if the president has a
vision and that's something certainly
we're all willing to entertain and
examine when the time comes
that's not a yes
I believe that the president has been
doing a very good job so far and
um you know should he run again I think
that I you know I think it's it's we'll
take a look at it
yeah I will cross that bridge we'll take
a look at it
so what they're really saying this is
their latest talking point is we don't
like Joe Biden and we never have they've
got nothing to do with Joe Biden turns
out David Axelrod and Joe Scarborough
and the other professional Liars who
foisted this senile mannequin on America
are now trying to run away from him
the New York Times which is their
newsletter ran a front page story two
days ago on Sunday about Joe Biden's
mental decline really
that topic was completely off limits
just a year ago you couldn't say it
the New York Times quoted when DNC
officials advising Biden to announce now
right after the midterms that he's not
running again is David Axelrod
Mastermind of the Obama victories put it
himself quote the presidency is a
monstrously taxing job and the Stark
realities the president would be closer
to 90 than 80 at the end of a second
term and that would be a major issue
in other words he's too freaking old
Biden's got dementia who knew
well actually they all knew and they all
knew all along and they should not be
allowed at this late date to evade their
culpability for knowing and lying about
it they committed this crime
these people are cynical they're
ruthless they're morally disfigured and
if you need more proof of that consider
how they're treating poor Kamala Harris
they've abandoned Kamala Harris
completely it's shocking really given
that just 18 months ago these very same
people were yelling at you about how
lucky you were to have this historically
Indian black female vice president the
very first in history it was thrilling
that got emotional just thinking about
it Kamala Harris was that wonderful
here's a recap Kamala Harris is being
sworn in the first woman vice president
and our first woman vice president we'll
see our first woman vice president it
will be a historic day Kamala Harris
will be the first woman Vice President
of the United States we marked the
swearing into the first woman in
American history elected to national
office vice president Kamala Harris
don't tell me things can't change
don't tell me things can't change oh
they can change and they have that was
just the other day we were getting
Goosebumps listening to it but now
they're ghosting Kamala Harris like a
bad Tinder date they're pretending she
doesn't exist in effect in doing that
the Democratic party is embracing white
supremacy how well Democratic Party
leaders plan to deny Harris a job that
she has earned as Democratic nominee and
replace her in the next cycle with yet
another wait for it now white man let's
try Beto how about mayor Pete notice a
theme Here pale and male as they're
forever telling us
because it turns out diversity isn't
actually our strength Equity inclusion
are fine if you're hiring middle
managers at a big company you would
never hire a middle-aged white diet
Citibank that's probably illegal same
with the Airlines and hospitals who've
got way too many white male pilots and
heart surgeons and Supreme Court
Justices the bite Administration tells
us that constantly they seem to mean
that they use doj to enforce their rules
yet somehow the most anti-white
political party in the English-speaking
world is suddenly pushing another white
man for president how does that work Joe
Biden and Friends Ron claim well it
turns out the presidency is a different
thing affirmative action is essential
for vice presidents obviously that's how
he got Kamal Harris in the first place
but not for presidents presidents have
too much power so the usual diversity
standards don't apply we've had 46 male
white pres white male presidents in a
row the Democratic party wants you to
have another
not so fast racists hold on a second now
the rest of official washes may be
completely on board with this coup
against Kamala Harris who again earned
the job
they may be willing to stand back and
allow America's highest ranking woman of
color to be degraded and humiliated in
the pages of the New York Times but
we're not
We Believe Kamala Harris is a human
being with hopes and dreams and
aspirations she's a first in so many
ways she celebrated Kwanzaa before it
was even invented
of course now that Oprah is retired
Carmel Harris is America's main source
of life-affirming aphorisms that don't
actually mean anything
watch this Montage which we have
lovingly collected and ask yourself how
anyone could stand in the way of this
woman becoming president United States
you know when we talk about our children
I know for this group we all believe
that when we talk about the children of
the community
they are a children of the community
and so what we
asked is on an electric school bus on an
electric bus no exhaust
no diesel smell
it is time for us to do what we have
been doing and that time is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
this whole thing about the Border we've
been to the Border we've been to the
Border you haven't been to the Border
and I haven't been to Europe and I mean
I don't think you guys and my pronouns
are she her and hers she her
she would look down at me and Kamala
what do you want what do you want and I
look back up at her and I said Freedom
you're gonna literally see the craters
on the moon with your own eyes with your
own eyes I'm telling you we must
together work together to see where we
are
where we are headed but also see it as a
moment yes to together it is the
perspective of of a woman who grew up a
a black child in America who was also a
prosecutor who also has a mother who
arrived here at the age of 19 from India
who also you know likes hip-hop like
what do you want to know what do you
want to know
she's unbelievable
you would deny that person a chance to
serve that is the person the Democratic
insiders are tonight ladies and
gentlemen trying to remove from the
public stage and if no one else to say
it we will it's wrong
despite appearances Kamala Harris is not
a disposable consumer product
she's a pioneer
do you know what she went through trying
to get a fair Shake in the systemically
racist countries the daughter of college
professors it wasn't easy you know how
hard she worked at one point she even
dated Montel Williams few would go that
far but Kamala Harris did no wonder
she's sick and tired of being sick and
tired we get it watch as she did the
work and unpacked her generational
trauma live on television for you
you know there was a little girl in
California who was part of the second
class to integrate her public schools
and she was bussed to school every day
and that little girl was me
that little girl was me now that little
girl actually grew up in French speaking
Canada not in the Jim Crow South but
whatever look what she's become now
simply because she's a [ __ ] and no one
likes or even agrees on how to pronounce
her first name the Democratic party is
trying to throw Harris away toss her out
the window like I used Big Mac rapper
now Kamala Harris may be stained with
Secret Sauce but she deserves more than
that yes she does mediocrity is no
excuse for firing someone
a low IQ a terrible personality a total
inability to do the prescribed job those
are not reasons to deny someone a job
the by Administration has told us that
repeatedly by the way democracy plays a
role in this too you just saw the woman
who Liz Cheney tells us a lot got 81
million votes in the last election
that's the most votes of any vice
president in history that's more votes
than Liz Cheney's dad got
so denying Kamala Harris the Democratic
nomination in 2024 is nothing less than
a form of insurrection it's an attack on
democracy and on our sacred Norms it's
disinformation probably Russian and
origin whatever it is we cannot allow it
and as long as this show is on the air
we won't tonight we are endorsing Kamala
D Harris for the 2024 Democratic
primaries she deserves it and so do
Democrats they created her they should
be forced to live with her and anyone
who disagrees with that is by definition
a racist
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight